hello everybody welcome to the Thursday
evening class and the start we're going
to be talking about a very specific
topic today
it's called momentum when you have the
momentum in a game what do you do
anybody can explain that what is
momentum in a chess game do you know
initially it's very similar yeah
initiative initiative you know where you
have your piece are getting active or a
momentum where let's say you were
defending and defending and suddenly
your opponent made a mistake and it
shifted it to your favor you have the
momentum understanding when you have the
momentum the you know and following it
through is very very important ok so
it's very similar to initiative you know
momentum so today topic will be momentum
and I prepared four different positions
for you so this is position number one
okay this is a game between a very
strong grandmaster from poland voi - ik
we taschek against Janousek Janousek I'm
not familiar with a player but we
taschek is over 2700 strong grandmaster
who has defeated magnus carlsen in a
classical game by the way okay so in
this game you know white to play and win
we taschek found the continuation so
it's about five you know about five
moves you have to calculate okay five
moves and white wins - so let's set up
and see who is gonna be able to find
this solution and we'll take some
answers from our YouTube audience
welcome to all the people who are
watching us on a YouTube channel and so
let's start thinking now we're going to
pause for a little bit so you can think
white to play and win use the momentum
knowing that you have the momentum is a
huge advantage often times we were
playing games we don't realise that this
is the momentum so having this position
there it's clear that this is the
momentum
what a shocks opponent is the last name
is J a and a s za k I presume it's
another polish player but I'm not
familiar with him
Jenna's Zack janaszak played in 2013
2013 game okay so what did super
grandmasters rapid this was a rapid by
the way white surprisingly won this very
very quickly okay I don't know what was
blacks last move you know but it perhaps
you could have been it was just an h5
played something like that or he brought
the Queen from c5 25 but whatever it
happened now you have an opportunity to
win this game and you have to do this
so I want to give you a little bit of
time to think so you can you can find
the idea again we're looking at
something very strong very concrete okay
we're looking at something very very
concrete here
we have a couple of more minutes I will
give you
which idea what piece looks kind of
awkward here to you in this position
which piece looks kind of awkward huh
in this position it feels like that this
piece is bit out of place yes absolutely
correct thinking yes this piece is
misplaced
it's kind of in a situation where there
are some attacks you know but we don't
want to just attack like this because
you can check one maybe take you know so
obviously he saw the movie before but he
thought his okay after 94 or you know
Quincy watch it but there is another
idea that he did not calculate all the
way that he did not calculate all the
way
when you see a piece that is placed
awkwardly the very first thing you have
to do is do what
what's the idea that comes into mind
when you see this piece is not placed on
the right square do what drop it
absolutely exactly that's what you got
to do in this position trap it when the
pieces misplace you trap it try to
attack it
excuse me yes
rook g5 now when you play this book root
G 5 where can the Queen go to any square
you can go to no right so obviously he's
gonna play this move
now what you gonna do
correct correct in the back excellent I
can see your perfect
he takes now keep going don't give up
don't give up Bishop d3 can you move
little bit that way so I can see you
you're behind bend so just this well a
little bit more yeah move your chair a
little bit more little bit more uh-huh
excellent X and now I can see you
so you're saying Bishop d3 right bad he
goes Queen d2 before or something
so something better something stronger
you have here correct now where is the
queen going guys it's very limited the
limited amount of squares now this piece
has here so where are we going where is
it going huh
h4 continued
continue
correct what can he do and you cannot do
anything else Lukas guard everything
this guard it takes the pawn and then
what do you do
fantastic excellent play very good ok
Bravo guys you just played like a super
grandmaster moy taschek ok
you understand the momentum it's where
you have something you have to go boom
every move you gotta attack attack
attack attack and here you drop it ok
that is what is it called momentum when
you're attacking opponent got it get the
momentum that's very very important for
you to remember ok get the momentum
moving forward
excellent job ok so once again let's
demonstrate this for everybody here what
is the first move has to go here no
choice what is the second move perfecto
perfect perfect ok moving forward
nice work ok
okay the next position I want to bring
to your attention let me set it up
all right this game is played by
actually friend of mine who was she was
here recently doing a commentary in
Russian anastacio Karlovich against rich
Rijo Renko these are probably female
I don't know black but so Karla which is
you know so she is playing white and she
came up with a fantastic idea here okay
what to do here
again you have to calculate a little bit
about five six moves and try to find the
crushing idea the killing below okay
here that's what you have to do
what do you see I mean it just really
black really needs one more move you
know to strengthen hip position like
something like rook a8 and everything is
gonna be defended so you really need to
do something about that
King takes you six I have to Quincy four
okay let's see what Mario is suggesting
take take check now what about this more
value queen depart
ninety-five
well your queen is hanging
Thanks
now what were you sacrificing everything
you muster you better have the mate
because if you don't then there's gonna
be a problem
okay well you down orokin I mean
best-case scenario you have a perpetual
yeah no maintenance I mean there's no
mate if you had made that momentum but
here a nice five
we also take
okay
so you got the first move right Mario
but the second or you need to improve on
the second move
perfect okay well after rookie one you
have to analyze a few ideas here okay so
well first yeah this is not much to
analyze it's just mate okay and if he
goes backwards that's made because of
check
check and mate and the point is if you
go here then I have this check check
check it mate
okay
so
so he he go check of course he's gonna
go 95 hoping that maybe maybe this one
will do something
what do you do
yeah you can try to clear a four and
claim you have a good position yeah you
might be able to but better better
better
okay
I hope takes e5 check
now he has to take
now you can go here and here
well yeah medium one here can you please
find out
alright then if it goes here
you know sound check yeah what about
this you gotta take it
no one more chef 26
he goes here
check
take the Quinn or you can take the Queen
or mate you know
better better
24 check now he goes here
show me the mate
well just made in one right made in one
just do it okay
if you ever made in one just do it
mm-hmm so yeah just expose the shield
and you have this meeting again if it
goes here now what do you do
perfect
now
mm-hmm
not saying she's probably gonna go here
and now this gives you the opportunity
to win
context
now he takes mate if you take
7mate okay any questions
so again fantastic play by feeded a
feedom wfm anastacio Karlovich okay so
once again let's go over the solution
here so you can see the ideas let's go
expose the opponents position okay in
positions like this you have to be very
active very dynamic to open up the
position to uncover that shield okay to
uncover that shield so opponent cannot
do anything
got it let's go let's go for it go
fantastic continue fantastic
continue yep
perfect
if he goes up you just go Bishop e7
check take the Queen if it goes here
made entry let's go yep
yep perfect excellent job okay next
position we're moving forward to some
good calculations needed okay I know
this is not easy stuff but I wanted to
use something that will be challenging
for you guys not all of that usually
they go by intuition you know they try
to calculate as much as possible but
like a lot of these lines that just did
it go by intuition you just feel that
that's that's gonna work
you know you after you play for a very
long time and you play a lot of strong
players you develop an intuition and a
few for the positions all right this is
a game between Grandmaster Jabba and his
opponent is a player named Ruffman
probably an international master from
India or Bangladesh Rahman hmm so why do
play and win well actually sorry this is
different Joe bah bah - bah bah
not the stronger Baba's his brother
Belger Begler Joe Baba
White has a strong position but it
doesn't look like there is a clear-cut
yeah you can take this but you're gonna
drop this you know so it's not quite
gonna work you know
camp
now you really want to get your Bishop
to c4 but how
now what to do here how to proceed in
this position
what do you think you know if you can
get our Bishop into the game now that
will be very very very strong for you
we're talking about a light square
bishop that is undeveloped see this
piece is a little bit undeveloped if you
give life time he will take on these
seven then you have good development so
you shouldn't be giving down much time
so again that means we have to play
energetically to show the momentum okay
that's where the momentum is now let's
see
correct correct
rookie one now well everything else
everything is pretty bad so he has to
take this to at least get rid of this
okay I mean if you go this way he takes
this way if you go this way if you go
this way this is a problem here there is
a tactical problem here who can see it
who can see the tactical problem yeah
but there is King g6 there
scure how
correct yes Rock takes takes continue
mm-hmm you win the game okay and if it
tries to go here we'll give a check it
goes away we take number four and next
one you're just gonna take on a five and
take well you're trading rook takes e5
here
yeah so
that's why and if you play Bishop takes
d7
obvious check into 6h 413 Bishop d3 so
here he was Bishop a5 and here you had
to deflect this by saying boom boom and
here M Bishop d3 is coming up okay
Bishop d2 very very strong position so
that's why why doesn't have a big choice
so he's gonna play sorry on rook e1 he's
gonna play Bishop takes T so that's the
best defense okay I mean at least
eliminating the pond now we have to
continue the attack continued to attack
strongly
Bishop c4 Bravo continue
mmm-maybe get the fish good
and now
well what's the most natural move here
guys
rope to such a night
perfect now he has to go here trying to
push it and this is a huge problem ok
undeveloped and exposed King you know
when your pieces are not developed it's
just going to be a problem
and in this case it's a huge problem ok
now gotta keep the momentum remember
whatever you do you keep the momentum
okay
correct
not yet you need to occupy this G 5
square G H 5 square okay there are there
are other ways to win here you can check
check check
take pawns but this is really nice this
one idea is particularly nice
look what just so you couldn't let
that's king h6
g4 has to take no choice and now don't
trash the move order is important here
okay the move order is very important
okay to start with because if you don't
play the right move order their blood
gets additional defenses and you don't
want that to happen you're actually
giving made here
brookey six but he can go back to f7
then he goes King h6 no that's just for
us here's Bishop d6 defense there so you
actually want to leave the King here for
now
yes h4 now you threaten h5 check King
goes over to ship g7 mate okay
so he paid 96
and now
mate
or you if you're a fan of a bishop made
this is pretty nice as well all right
excellent excellent all right so let's
go back and try to understand how this
is all happening so here's two major
things I see in blacks position anybody
can tell me the two major flaws in a
blacks position right now on the
underdeveloped yeah
on the developed and what is this here
King is weak right underdeveloped and
the king is weak okay so remember that
it was happening in a game played in
2003 long time ago so Ruki won now take
rookie won and getting the bishop out
and going Bishop c4
alright guys at the end we are going to
do a study okay there's a really
difficult study so but again this is for
you for our live audience in st. Louis
chess club and for our audience we have
on YouTube tear white to play and win
there are no pawns
so that means you can only win if you
checkmate him or somehow win his queen
and still checkmate them okay there are
no other ways we don't have any more
palms to Queen or do anything like that
first of all I believe it's more or less
clear what you need to do I think
yes in the back correct now he is gonna
go here now don't rush there are two
tempting options here okay one maybe
it's a little bit more tempting than
another but you have to play the best
not the ones that are tempting just the
one that you think is the best
now you have two natural moles here -
very tempting options
better
correct
now goes here
correct
anything goes here
now strong will need it this is this is
the correct idea but now strong will
need it
huh better better better
look at that Queen what can you do 96
this is this is the hardest move for
this position that's why I chose this
one it's the hardest moment here
no no no no this is fine just you gotta
check him live a different way so you
don't want it to go like this two
squares he cannot go because you have a
fork okay if you go back he's gonna go
back to have six or he'll come up 24
don't give him the e4 square because if
you give me four square he is escaping
yes now if you go here and here
it's mate I mean you lose the Queen so
you have to go here
now quiet move that wins the game the
quiet move
so now it's quiet move you have here
Queen D three correct yes after you play
Queen D three you are threatening to
play 96 and give a mate okay after 96
it's just gonna be a maid so you cannot
do anything if he goes back to e5 you
have him forked okay and winning the
Quinn and if he takes here and if he
takes here now what are you gonna do
Queen have fun check fantastic and
that's using the skewer tactic okay
skewer tactic to win the game
excellent this is a quiet move this was
the hardest move here I mean you know
Queen h7 is not easy either but this
mooches Quincy is just absolutely
brilliant
setting up the mate with 96 and if you
go back 25 just 97 then King cannot go
anywhere so just really nice study so
let's do this one more time
go ahead what's correct I cannot go to
back back I get made it I cannot go to
here I get me I have to go here now what
he do
effect if he goes to h6 it's just amazed
now attacking the if I go back here then
it's a mate or 25 so I have to go King
f5 and Queen at 7 check can I go to the
f6 forbidden and E 5 equals a 97 check
winning the pieces so has to go here on
the move
yeah 23 the covers up the squares and
sets up the 96 mate
excellent excellent well very well very
well done guys
excellent job so this disc will conclude
the first lecture 6:30 lecture so we're
going to take a short break now and
we're going to continue the 7:30 class
you're going to go over some of the
current games that are going on right
now ok
all right thanks for coming
[Music]